There's this thing that happens in the first episode of the TV show Watchmen, which I finally saw last month. I'm behind. A woman is driving with her son on a sunny day, and suddenly the sky darkens and squids drop from the sky, like a hailstorm or something. But they're little squids, each one-- I don't know-- the length of your finger.
电视剧《守望者》的第一集里发生了一件事，我上个月终于看了这部剧。我落后了。一个女人在一个阳光明媚的日子里带着儿子开车，突然天空变暗，鱿鱼从天而降，就像冰雹什么的。但那是些小鱿鱼，每一只——我不知道——大约有你的手指那么长。
Cars on the road pull over and wait. Squids land on them and on the ground, making this soggy layer of squid on the road. And then soon enough-- again, like a hailstorm-- it stops. Sun comes back up. Everybody starts their car again, heads to wherever they're heading, just like the most normal thing in the world. No big deal, just another squid drop.
路上的车停下来等待。鱿鱼落在车上和地上，在路上形成了一层湿漉漉的鱿鱼。然后很快——同样，就像冰雹一样——它停了。太阳出来了。每个人重新发动汽车，前往他们要去的地方，就像那是世界上最平常的事情一样。没什么大不了的，只不过又下了一场鱿鱼雨。
And when I saw that, I felt like that is exactly how things happen. That's how things feel. That's what everything feels like right now. Inconceivable stuff goes down all the time these days. And it's like, you can get used to anything. You know what I mean?
当我看到那一幕时，我觉得这就是事情发生的方式。事情就是这种感觉。现在一切给人的感觉都是这样。这些日子里，不可思议的事情一直在发生。就像是你习惯了任何事情。你知道我的意思吗？
Every few days, more Americans die from COVID than died in 9/11. Wildfires are raging and continue to just rage. The president won't disavow white supremacists in a televised debate. I'm used to all that. That's just daily life, you know?
每隔几天，死于新冠病毒的美国人就比9/11事件中死亡的人数还要多。野火肆虐，并且还在继续肆虐。总统在电视辩论中拒绝谴责白人至上主义者。我已经习惯了这一切。这就是日常生活，你懂吗？
Or there's this example of "you can get used to anything." Jay was having a normal, stressful day for 2020, meaning he does his job from his apartment on a computer at his kitchen table on Zoom. But he's also got to deal with his children during the workday.
或者还有这个关于“你可以习惯任何事情”的例子。杰伊在2020年度过了平常且充满压力的一天，这意味着他在公寓的厨房餐桌上用电脑通过Zoom远程办公。但他还得在工作日照顾孩子。
So a couple weeks ago, he's a college professor and he's preparing a lecture for a class. And he's anxious about that, and he wants it to be good. And then at 3 o'clock, he has to go run, get his kids, and bring them home. And he and his kids get back to their building at 3:20. And he's trying to move quickly because his class starts at 3:30. And he and his two kids get on the elevator to head up to their apartment.
所以两周前，他作为一名大学教授正在准备一门课的讲座。他对此感到焦虑，想把课讲好。下午3点，他得去接孩子回家。他和孩子们在3点20分回到他们居住的楼里。他试图快速移动，因为他的课3点30分就开始了。他和两个孩子进了电梯准备回公寓。
And then all of a sudden, I feel the elevator start to drop. It's like a half-second feeling, like when you're on a roller coaster. And thankfully, it stops.
突然间，我感觉到电梯开始下坠。大概只有半秒钟的感觉，就像坐在过山车上一样。谢天谢地，它停住了。
How far do you guys drop?
你们坠落了多远？
I don't know, just probably a couple of stories.
我不知道，大概就两层楼吧。
You dropped a few stories?
你们坠落了几层楼？
Yeah, and I look, and it's stuck at the third floor.
是的，我看了看，它卡在三楼了。
They push a button to call for help. And they're told somebody is going to be there to fix things, but it's going to take a little while. And they wait.
他们按下按钮呼救。有人告诉他们会有人来修理，但需要一点时间。于是他们等待着。
And my kids are starting to bicker with one another. And my daughter starts getting upset.
我的孩子们开始互相争吵。我女儿开始变得沮丧。
She's eight years old. And part of what's happening, Jay says, is that her big brother, who is 10 years old, has actually been stuck in an elevator once before when he was little. So he's being all, what's the big deal?
她八岁。杰伊说，发生这种情况的部分原因是她10岁的哥哥小时候曾被困在电梯里过。所以他表现得无所谓，这有什么大不了的？
He was not rattled at all. And in fact, she starts to get upset. He starts to tell her that she's overreacting, and that makes her more upset. And so I had to calm her down and tell him to stop teasing her. And then we took a couple selfies. And I tried to make it like a fun thing we're all going to remember and look back on and laugh on. And so that kind of changed the mood in the elevator a little bit, at least briefly.
他一点也没被吓到。事实上，她开始心烦意乱。他开始嘲笑她反应过度，这让她更生气了。所以我不得不让她冷静下来，并让他停止逗她。然后我们拍了几张自拍。我试着把它变成一件我们以后会记住、回想起来会大笑的有趣事情。这在某种程度上稍微改变了电梯里的气氛，至少短暂地改变了。
So, kids momentarily OK, Jay gets back to the other urgent matter that's on his mind-- his class. It's over 300 students, this big intro psychology class, which still has not started. There's still just enough time for him to quickly tap out a message on his phone-- "Dear class, I am currently trapped in an elevator in my apartment building. So I'll join the Zoom call and start teaching once I'm safely out of here."
孩子们暂时没事了，杰伊又回到了他关心的另一件紧急事项——他的课。那是一门有300多名学生的大型心理学入门课，至今还没开始。他还有足够的时间在手机上快速打出一行字——“亲爱的同学们，我目前被困在我公寓楼的电梯里。所以我一安全出去就会加入Zoom会议开始讲课。”
Push Send, message goes out, and then-- nothing, right? They just stay put. And Jay starts to worry about his students, who are waiting for him on the Zoom call. 10 minutes pass, 20.
点击发送，消息发出去了，然后——什么都没发生，对吧？他们只是待在原地。杰伊开始担心在Zoom会议上等他的学生们。10分钟过去了，20分钟。
And half an hour in, he decides he's going to try to teach the class on his phone from the elevator, which takes a little technical wrangling. He has to download Zoom to his phone with barely one bar of service, blah blah blah. OK, this part is boring. But after a while, OK, no video, voice only, he's in!
半小时后，他决定尝试在电梯里用手机讲课，这需要一些技术上的折腾。他必须在只有一格信号的情况下将Zoom下载到手机上，巴拉巴拉。好吧，这一部分很无聊。但过了一会儿，没视频，只有声音，他进去了！
And I join the Zoom class. And I'm trying to talk to them. And I can hear their voices. And the students are all chit chatting with themself. And I can hear them kind of speculating about what might be happening to me, and they're laughing. And I am trying to get their attention. And they're all talking, and they couldn't hear me. And so I'm shouting at this point. "It's me, it's Jay. I'm here. Hi, guys." [LAUGHS]
我加入了Zoom课堂。我试图跟他们说话。我能听到他们的声音。学生们都在窃窃私语。我能听到他们在那推测我到底出了什么事，他们还在笑。我试图引起他们的注意。他们都在说话，听不见我。所以我当时在喊。“是我，我是杰伊。我在这。嘿，伙计们。” [笑声]
So in the elevator, what's happening is, you're a grown man shouting into his phone. Is that right?
所以在电梯里，发生的情况是一个成年男人对着手机大喊大叫。是这样吗？
Yeah. And eventually I can hear someone say, "Hey, wait, shh. I think I hear our professor. I think he's back."
是的。最终我听到有人说：“嘿，等等，嘘。我想我听到教授的声音了。我想他回来了。”
He has a moment of panic, like what am I going to say. And then he launches in. With no notes, none of his slides. He gives the lecture that he'd planned.
他经历了一阵恐慌，心想我该说些什么。然后他开始了。没有笔记，没有幻灯片。他讲了他准备好的讲座。
And I can't see them, and they can't see me. But it was working. It was all kind of coming back to me. And I was able to deliver it, and I had their attention.
我看不见他们，他们也看不见我。但这行得通。一切都回到了我的脑海里。我能够讲出来，并且吸引了他们的注意力。
So it started to seem normal?
所以它开始显得正常了？
Yeah, it starts to seem normal. Yeah, eventually, I had adapted. My kids are being quiet. They're listening.
是的，开始显得正常了。是的，最终我适应了。我的孩子们很安静。他们在听。
Can I ask you, do you remember how long it took? How many minutes did it take before this started to seem normal?
我可以问一下，你记得花了多久吗？在这一切开始显得正常之前花了多少分钟？
I would say about four or five minutes.
我会说大约四五分钟吧。
Four or five minutes! We are very adaptable creatures. Soon enough, the elevator jolts and starts to move again. Jay gets back to his apartment, sits down at the kitchen table, logs onto Zoom, and teaches a couple hundred kids from his kitchen, which, of course, is also totally weird, but after months of doing that, it feels totally normal.
四五分钟！我们是非常容易适应的生物。没过多久，电梯猛地晃动了一下，又开始移动了。杰伊回到公寓，坐在餐桌旁，登录Zoom，从厨房里给几百个学生上课，这当然也非常怪异，但在经历了几个月的这种生活后，一切感觉完全正常。
Hey, did you consider not doing the class? Did you consider canceling?
嘿，你有考虑过不讲那节课吗？你有考虑过取消吗？
It's funny because that night, when I told my partner about this, she was like, why didn't you just cancel? And she's a professor, but it's one of those things where it didn't cross my mind when I was in the situation.
很有趣，因为那天晚上，当我把这件事告诉我的伴侣时，她说，你为什么不直接取消呢？她也是一位教授，但有些事情是我身处那种境地时根本没想到的。
My mind, early in that day, had been focused on being able to navigate this complex situation that was going to be stressful-- getting my kids and getting home, and then getting the lecture ready, which I had been prepping all day. And so that had determined each little step I made. And I never really stopped to think that I just shouldn't do it.
那一天，我的心思一直集中在如何应对这个压力重重的复杂情况上——接孩子、回家，然后准备讲座，我整天都在为此做准备。这就是我每一步行动的准则。我从未真正停下来想过我不应该去上这节课。
That's all of us right now. Our lives this year are so strange. And we just do the next task and the next one after that and the next one after that, and we do not think about how weird things have gotten.
这就是现在的我们。我们今年的生活太奇怪了。我们只是做下一个任务，接着是下一个，再下一个，我们不去想事情变得有多么奇怪。
Each little step naturally led to the next step. And then it wasn't until I left the situation hours later, I was looking at it and realizing how absurd it was.
每一步都自然而然地引向了下一步。直到几小时后离开那个场景，我看着它，才意识到那是多么荒谬。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, on our program, people trapped in small spaces, stuck in a situation, and coping because they have no choice.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，在我们的节目中，讲述那些被困在狭小空间里，陷入困境，因为别无选择只能应付的人们。
Jay, I think it's pretty clear, was not too bothered by his short time in the elevator, but in our other stories today, it is people who are stuck in a small space for way longer. In the first half of our program, we have a story where things get pretty dire. And in the second half, it's not nearly so difficult. It's musicians who are confined to a tiny space for years, an uncomfortably tiny space. And can I say, things get pretty weird there, too. Stay with us.
我觉得很明显，杰伊并没有太被他在电梯里的那段短暂时光所困扰，但在我们今天的其他故事中，人们被困在狭小空间里的时间要长得多。在节目的前半部分，我们将讲述一个相当可怕的故事。在后半部分，情况就没有那么困难了。是那些被限制在一个狭小空间里多年的音乐家们，一个狭小到让人不舒服的空间。而且我可以告诉你，那里发生的事情也相当怪异。留下来收听我们的节目。
Act One, The People Up the Stairs. So we start today with a couple who've been penned into a small space for months now, hiding in an attic because their lives are on the line, surrounded by musty furniture and stacks of old paintings that are collecting dust. Kevin Sieff talked to them about the truly jaw-dropping story of how they got there.
第一幕，楼上的人。我们今天从一对被关在一个狭小空间里几个月的夫妇开始，他们躲在阁楼里，因为他们的生命正处于危险之中，周围是发霉的家具和成堆积满灰尘的旧画。凯文·西夫与他们聊了聊他们如何来到那里的令人震惊的故事。
The attic has creaky wood floors and one small window, but they try not to go close to it. They don't want to be seen. The ceilings are low. Moises, who's 6'1", has to crouch, but Jessica's fine. They spend their time obsessing over not being heard. They try not to talk above a whisper or walk on the creaking floorboards. Even sleeping is stressful.
阁楼里有吱吱作响的木地板和一扇小窗户，但他们尽量不去靠近它。他们不想被看见。天花板很低。身高6英尺1英寸的莫伊塞斯不得不蜷缩着身子，但杰西卡还好。他们把时间花在担心自己被听见上。他们尽量不低声说话，也不走在吱吱作响的地板上。连睡觉都有压力。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
When we sleep, Moises snores, and it scares me. And sometimes I wake him up in the night when I hear that he's snoring. I say, "Moises, try not to snore." But I don't think it's something that is under his control. But it still bothers me because it's something that I don't think he should do.
我们睡觉时，莫伊塞斯会打鼾，这让我害怕。有时我听到他在打鼾，会在夜里把他叫醒。我说：“莫伊塞斯，试着别打鼾。”但我觉得这不是他能控制的。但这仍然困扰着我，因为我认为他不该这样做。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Do you have to worry about every noise that you guys make?
你们必须担心你们发出的每一点声音吗？
Yeah, we have to be like ghosts in this house.
是的，我们必须像这房子里的鬼魂一样。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
How Moises and Jessica ended up in this attic, it goes back to how they met. It was 2016 on an anti-government WhatsApp group. They were both activists against the regime of Daniel Ortega, who has ruled Nicaragua on and off for 40 years. Then they started seeing each other at protests and meetings.
莫伊塞斯和杰西卡是如何住进这个阁楼的，这要追溯到他们的相识。那是2016年在一个反政府的WhatsApp群组里。他们都是反对丹尼尔·奥尔特加政权的活动人士，奥尔特加已经统治尼加拉瓜40年了，断断续续。然后他们开始在抗议和会议上见到对方。
Jessica saw the nerdy guy, unafraid to go on national television, wearing a mask with the president's face on it and an x over the mouth, demanding freedom of expression. Moises saw the woman with the big brown eyes, often the last person to back down when the police showed up.
杰西卡看到了那个书呆子气的男人，他不怕上国家电视，戴着一张印有总统脸庞且嘴上画着X的面具，要求言论自由。莫伊塞斯看到了那个有着一双棕色大眼睛的女人，当警察出现时，她往往是最后一个退缩的人。
At one protest, when 200 police closed in on a group of maybe 20 protesters, Moises looked for a place to run. But then he saw Jessica and another woman walk right up to the armed officers and start yelling in their faces.
在一次抗议活动中，当200名警察包围了一群大概20名抗议者时，莫伊塞斯在寻找逃跑的地方。但他看到了杰西卡和另一名女性径直走向全副武装的警察，并开始对他们大吼大叫。
So I kind of got brave also. I went to the frontline and stand with them, shoulder to shoulder, doing the same thing.
所以我也有点勇敢起来了。我走向前线，与她们并肩站在一起，做着同样的事情。
It's kind of a crazy moment to start a relationship with someone. You're in the middle of basically a firing line, with this girl that you just started dating.
这算是和一个刚开始约会的人建立关系时的一个疯狂时刻。你基本上正处在火线上，和你刚开始交往的女孩在一起。
Yeah. What I thought was, if they're going to kill me, I'm going to die happy right now, at least.
是的。我当时想的是，如果他们要杀了我，至少我现在死而无憾了。
They got married and Moises adopted Jessica's daughter, Camila. He got a job at a Sprint call center, talking to people from the States all day. Jessica worked for a company that made solar panels.
他们结婚了，莫伊塞斯收养了杰西卡的女儿卡米拉。他在Sprint呼叫中心找到了一份工作，整天和美国人通话。杰西卡在一家制造太阳能电池板的公司工作。
But still, their relationship was built around their activism. One parent picked up Camila at school, while the other organized a rally or held a press conference. At home, near the little girl's pile of toys, they kept masks for tear gas.
尽管如此，他们的关系还是围绕着他们的政治行动。一位家长在学校接卡米拉，另一位则组织集会或举行新闻发布会。在家里，靠近小女孩的一堆玩具旁，他们放着防催泪瓦斯的口罩。
But the government's response got harsher. The regime began kidnapping its opponents. Moises was grabbed by four or five men in unmarked cars and taken to El Chipote, an infamous prison documented by human rights groups as being a state-run torture site. A warning-- this next bit includes descriptions of violence.
但政府的反应变得更加严厉。政权开始绑架异见者。莫伊塞斯被四五个坐着无牌照车辆的男人抓走，带到了埃尔奇波特（El Chipote），那是人权组织记录在案的臭名昭著的监狱，是一个由国家经营的酷刑场所。警告——接下来的内容包含暴力描述。
They were hitting me in the head, in the stomach, in the legs, and they said, we're going to kill you, motherfucker. You're never going to get out. Now we got you. Now we got you. And they stripped me naked, did some things that they did to me that I will-- that my wife doesn't even know that they did to me because I don't feel like I want to tell her.
他们击打我的头部、腹部、腿部，他们说，我们要杀了你，混蛋。你永远出不去了。现在我们抓到你了。现在我们抓到你了。他们剥光了我的衣服，对我做了一些事，我……我妻子甚至都不知道他们对我做了什么，因为我不想告诉她。
They do all horrible things over there. They put electric shocks to your body. They put a-- I don't know if you know what a-- a police stick they use to beat you up. They introduce that into your anal cavity, so make sure they make you talk.
他们在那里做所有可怕的事情。他们用电击你的身体。他们用一个……我不知道你知不知道什么……警棍，他们用来殴打你。他们把它塞进你的肛门，以确保让你开口说话。
He was held for two days. Not long after they released him, Jessica went to a protest that was broken up by police. Officers kicked her in the stomach and hit her with the butt of a gun. She was pregnant. She lost the baby.
他被关了两天。他们释放他后不久，杰西卡去参加了一场抗议，抗议被警察驱散了。警察踢了她的肚子，用枪托打了她。她怀孕了。她流产了。
Late last year, they realized they couldn't stay anymore. They needed to escape, and their plan was to go to the US. And they had a good reason to think they would be welcomed there. Jessica and Moises' brand of activism, it was championed by Republicans, including the Trump administration, for its defiance of a left-wing autocrat. They were called freedom fighters. "We stand with you," Republican senators said in statements and tweets.
去年年底，他们意识到他们不能再待下去了。他们需要逃跑，他们的计划是去美国。他们有充分的理由认为自己会受到那里的欢迎。杰西卡和莫伊塞斯那种政治行动，受到了共和党人包括特朗普政府的支持，因为他们敢于挑战左翼独裁者。他们被称为自由战士。“我们与你们站在一起，”共和党参议员在声明和推文中说。
In 2018, Ted Cruz gave a whole speech about US support for Nicaraguan activists like them.
2018年，泰德·克鲁兹发表了整篇关于美国支持像他们这样的尼加拉瓜活动人士的演讲。
To the people of Nicaragua, the American people stand with you in your fight for freedom and for the rule of law. To the half million protesters who risked your lives, I say thank you. Thank you for your courage. And remember, truth has power.
致尼加拉瓜人民，美国人民在你们争取自由和法治的斗争中与你们站在一起。对于那50万冒险的抗议者，我要说谢谢。感谢你们的勇气。请记住，真理是有力量的。
That support, it's part of what made their asylum case seem winnable, because it fell under the category of political persecution. It was one sliver of the asylum system left intact, after years of dismantling.
这种支持是他们的庇护申请看起来有胜算的部分原因，因为它属于政治迫害类别。这是在多年来的拆解之后，仅存的一丝庇护系统。
In all sorts of ways, getting asylum in the US has become almost impossible. Asylum seekers are being turned away at the border, told, "Nope, we're closed." Cases are incredibly hard to win even when they do get to the courts.
在各种意义上，在美国获得庇护已变得几乎不可能。寻求庇护者在边境被拒之门外，被告知，“不，我们关闭了。”即使他们能进入法院，案件也极其难以胜诉。
But the Trump administration did leave at least one window cracked. One of the few categories of asylum seekers that it purported to accept-- people who were threatened, tortured, jailed for their politics. Especially when their politics overlapped with US interests-- people like Moises and Jessica.
但特朗普政府确实留了一扇半开的窗。它声称接受的少数几种寻求庇护者之一——那些因为政治立场而受到威胁、折磨、监禁的人。尤其是当他们的政治立场与美国利益重叠时——像莫伊塞斯和杰西卡这样的人。
Moises and Jessica were a perfect asylum case for another reason. Their persecution was documented, and it was public. As activists, they had become famous. Their protests had been televised. They'd held nationally-broadcast press conferences. People recognized them in the streets all the time. Even the State Department had tweeted about specific confrontations they'd had with the paramilitary.
莫伊塞斯和杰西卡成为完美的庇护案例还有另一个原因。他们的迫害是有记录的，并且是公开的。作为活动人士，他们已经出名了。他们的抗议活动在电视上播出过。他们举行过全国广播的新闻发布会。人们一直在街上认出他们。甚至国务院也曾在推特上提到过他们与准军事部队的具体对抗。
At any other time in recent US history, they would likely have been admitted. But instead, they're in hiding. I wanted to understand why. I've been covering immigration for the last few years, and this, to me, felt like the last chapter in the disintegration of asylum. So I called Moises and Jessica in the attic to hear about their journey from start to finish, to learn what happened.
在美国近现代史上的任何其他时期，他们很可能都会被接纳。但相反，他们现在躲藏起来了。我想了解为什么。过去几年我一直在报道移民问题，对我来说，这感觉像是庇护制度崩溃的最后一章。所以我给阁楼里的莫伊塞斯和杰西卡打了电话，听听他们从始至终的旅程，了解到底发生了什么。
In late 2019, they started to get ready. Moises studied the US government website for the asylum requirements. He read about the importance of supporting your case with evidence. So he bought a black backpack, and he filled it with all the evidence he could gather-- videos of their protests and press conferences, reports from the Human Rights Commission and the State Department, statements from the White House and the Republican senators.
2019年底，他们开始准备。莫伊塞斯研究了美国政府网站上的庇护要求。他读到了用证据支持你的案子的重要性。所以他买了一个黑色背包，装满了能收集到的所有证据——他们抗议和新闻发布会的录像，人权委员会和国务院的报告，白宫和共和党参议员的声明。
Moises also wrote a five-page declaration, a long essay enumerating every threat, every beating he'd received from the government. He included the names of his torturers. He'd read online that the details could help his family's asylum case, so he was as specific as possible.
莫伊塞斯还写了一份五页的陈述，一篇长文，详述了他从政府那里受到的每一次威胁、每一次殴打。他列出了折磨者的名字。他从网上读到这些细节有助于他家人的庇护申请，所以他尽可能地具体。
The backpack took on a kind of sacred role for them. It was their proof that they were deserving of the sliver of asylum that remained available in the US. Then Moises and Jessica talked to Camila, their eight-year-old daughter. Camila is outgoing, loves LEGOs and TikTok videos. They sat her down, and Moises described all of the dangers they would face on their journey across the border. Camila told them she was ready to go.
这个背包对他们来说承担了一种神圣的角色。这是他们证明自己值得获得美国仅存的那一点庇护的证据。然后莫伊塞斯和杰西卡告诉了他们8岁的女儿卡米拉。卡米拉外向，喜欢乐高玩具和TikTok视频。他们让她坐下，莫伊塞斯描述了他们在穿越边境的旅途中将面临的所有危险。卡米拉告诉他们她准备好出发了。
At 3 o'clock one morning, they left their house outside of Managua and headed 2,000 miles north. By early July, they were moving through the desert of northern Mexico. It was scorching, and COVID cases were spiking. Moises had gamed everything out. He wrapped some of his asylum evidence in plastic in case it got wet. And he picked where they would cross the border-- Texas.
一天凌晨3点，他们离开马那瓜郊外的家，向北行进2000英里。到7月初，他们穿越了墨西哥北部的沙漠。天气炎热，新冠疫情病例激增。莫伊塞斯把一切都算计好了。他用塑料包裹了一些庇护证据，以防弄湿。他选好了他们要跨越边境的地方——得克萨斯州。
Since we heard so many things about the Texas senator Ted Cruz, which is a guy that always talk about the Nicaraguan regime and everything. We thought, oh my god, it was a good place because we're in Texas, which he is from.
因为我们听过太多关于得克萨斯参议员泰德·克鲁兹的事情，他是一个总是谈论尼加拉瓜政权的人。我们想，噢我的天，那是个好地方，因为我们在得克萨斯，那是他的地盘。
During tough moments on the journey to the border, Moises and Jessica had tried to convince Camila that the whole trip was a game. "It'll get more fun," they said. "Soon we'll be in Disney World. You'll eat a McDonald's hamburger." Camila played along at first, but by the time they got to the border, she was exhausted and scared. Jessica scouted out the Rio Grande. Neither she nor Camila could swim, so she nervously looked for the shallowest part.
在前往边境的艰难时刻，莫伊塞斯和杰西卡试图让卡米拉相信整个旅行是个游戏。“会变得更有趣的，”他们说，“很快我们就能去迪士尼乐园了。你会吃到麦当劳的汉堡。”卡米拉起初配合着，但当他们到达边境时，她已经精疲力竭且害怕了。杰西卡侦察了格兰德河。她和卡米拉都不会游泳，所以她紧张地寻找最浅的地方。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
So as we were walking into the river, it was as if fate had intervened. Because every time we took a step in the water, there was always a rock that we could see. That is, it was as if God had placed stones there so that we could walk and nothing would happen to us. The water never got that high. I don't even think it got above our knees. And so when we got to the other side, we saw the people from Border Patrol.
当我们走进河里时，就好像命运干预了一样。因为我们每在水里迈出一步，总能看到一块岩石。也就是说，就像上帝把石头放在那里，让我们能走过去，不至于发生任何事情。水从来没有那么深。我甚至觉得它都没没过我们的膝盖。所以当我们到达另一边时，我们看到了边境巡逻队的人。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Jessica felt a rush of relief. That's it, she thought. The hardest part is over. A Border Patrol agent got out of a truck. Moises had been planning for this moment, and he knew exactly what to do. And Moises speaks fluent English, which is incredibly unusual for an asylum seeker. He took off his backpack, and he spread out the pile of evidence supporting his asylum claim.
杰西卡感到一阵解脱。就是这样，她想。最困难的部分结束了。一名边境巡逻人员从卡车里出来。莫伊塞斯一直在为这一刻做计划，他确切地知道该怎么做。而且莫伊塞斯英语流利，这对于寻求庇护者来说是极其罕见的。他脱下背包，摊开了堆积如山的支持他庇护申请的证据。
I say right away, we're from Nicaragua. We apply for asylum. We're seeking political asylum. Here are these, including we have our passports. And they took notes and everything.
我立刻说，我们来自尼加拉瓜。我们申请庇护。我们正在寻求政治庇护。这里是这些东西，包括我们的护照。他们记了笔记，做了所有这些事。
The border patrol separated Moises from Jessica and Camila. They took his bag with all the evidence in it. For 12 days, they were detained in small, crowded tents. They were just sitting on the ground, waiting, in the same clothes they'd worn on the trip north.
边境巡逻队把莫伊塞斯和杰西卡及卡米拉分开了。他们带走了他装着所有证据的包。他们被拘留在拥挤的小帐篷里12天。他们只是坐在地上等待，穿着前往北方时穿的同一套衣服。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
When we got there, we were wet. When we crossed the river, our shoes and our pants got wet, and they did dry off, but they dried off on our bodies. And the shoes gave me a fungus on my feet because I didn't take them off. When we got there, we couldn't bathe. Our clothes were itching us so much, my underwear especially.
当我们到那里时，我们全身是湿的。当我们过河时，我们的鞋子和裤子湿了，它们确实干了，但是在我们的身体上干的。鞋子让我的脚长了霉菌，因为我没脱掉。当我们到那儿时，我们不能洗澡。我们的衣服让我们痒得厉害，尤其是我的内衣。
Moises kept repeating himself to janitors, guards, anyone. When can we apply for asylum, he asked. Where is my backpack? Finally, some guards came to get them. The guard said, "Everyone, get your stuff. We're taking you on a bus."
莫伊塞斯不断地对清洁工、守卫，任何人都重复着同样的话。我们什么时候可以申请庇护，他问。我的背包在哪里？最后，一些守卫来接他们。守卫说：“大家，拿上你们的东西。我们要把你们送上车。”
They handed Moises his backpack. It seemed to Jessica like they were about to be released and allowed to apply for asylum.
他们把背包递给莫伊塞斯。杰西卡看起来他们就要被释放并被允许申请庇护了。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
We were all happy. We were all hugging each other because the rumor was that when that bus arrived, it was going to take us to wherever we were going to be, like Miami or wherever the people meeting you were. And so we were happy because we thought that this entire bitter journey was going to come to an end.
我们都很高兴。我们都在拥抱对方，因为传言说那辆巴士一到，就会带我们去我们要去的地方，比如迈阿密或者任何接应我们的人那里。所以我们很高兴，因为我们认为这段苦难的旅程就要结束了。
She looked at Moises to see if he was also feeling hopeful, but Moises was more skeptical, and Jessica noticed. The US, it turns out, had used coronavirus as an excuse to shutter what was left of the US asylum system. In March, the Centers for Disease Control wrote an order saying that asylum seekers could be expelled because they pose a risk to public health during the pandemic. It later turned out that the order was conceived of by immigration officials at the White House, not medical experts.
她看向莫伊塞斯，看他是否也感到充满希望，但莫伊塞斯更怀疑，杰西卡注意到了。事实证明，美国一直在利用冠状病毒作为借口，关闭美国庇护制度中仅存的部分。3月，疾病控制中心写了一道命令，称寻求庇护者可能会被驱逐，因为在大流行期间他们对公共卫生构成风险。后来发现，该命令是由白宫移民官员构思的，而不是医疗专家。
And even though Moises, Jessica, and Camila tested negative for coronavirus while in custody, they could be deported. But they didn't know that. They were kept in an information black hole for a few days and then put in a van. No one would tell them where they were going.
尽管莫伊塞斯、杰西卡和卡米拉在拘留期间的新冠病毒检测结果均呈阴性，但他们仍可能被驱逐出境。但他们不知道。他们在信息黑洞中被关了几天，然后被送上一辆货车。没人告诉他们要去哪。
At what point do you realize that the van is going to the airport?
你在什么时候意识到货车是去机场的？
When after-- and when they stop the first time and then continue the trip, my wife told me that, oh, look, there's some signs, street signs that say "Airport," "Brownsville." Then we realized, oh my god, we're going to the airport. Then we're going back to Nicaragua.
当在他们第一次停车然后继续行程之后，我妻子告诉我，噢看，有些路牌写着“机场”、“布朗斯维尔”。然后我们意识到，噢我的天，我们要去机场了。然后我们要回到尼加拉瓜了。
Well, I started thinking, my god, what am I going to do? They're going to put me in jail again in Nicaragua. They're going to arrest me. They're going to shoot me in the head. They're going to disappear myself and my wife. They're going to send me to another Chipote for the rest of my life. Now they really make sure they're going to kill me.
好吧，我开始想，天哪，我要怎么办？他们会再次把我关进尼加拉瓜的监狱。他们会逮捕我。他们会朝我的脑袋开枪。他们会让我和我的妻子消失。他们会把我送进另一个奇波特（监狱），余生都关在那里。现在他们真的会确保他们要杀了我的。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Well, Camila was sleeping, and Moises was very nervous. I think it's one of the few times I've ever seen him cry. And it's really only a few times that he has, because I can tell you that I can count them on one hand and still have fingers left over.
嗯，卡米拉当时在睡觉，莫伊塞斯非常紧张。我想这是我见过他哭的极少数几次之一。真的只有几次而已，因为我可以说我单手就能数出来，而且还有剩。
But that day, I did see him cry. And he was crying a lot because, obviously, he was very scared.
但在那天，我确实看见他哭了。他哭得很厉害，因为很明显，他非常害怕。
And when you saw Moises crying, what did you say? Did you say anything?
当你看到莫伊塞斯哭时，你说了什么吗？你说了什么吗？
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Not really. I didn't say anything. I just looked at him, and he told me, "What are we going to do? What's going to happen? I'm scared that they're going to take me to the Chipote." And I didn't say anything. I kept quiet because I also thought that that was going to happen. So I couldn't tell him that that wasn't going to happen when, deep down, I felt that it would.
没什么。我什么也没说。我只是看着他，他告诉我：“我们要怎么办？会发生什么？我害怕他们会把我带到奇波特。”我什么都没说。我保持沉默，因为我也认为那会发生。所以我不能告诉他那不会发生，因为在内心深处，我觉得它会。
Moises and Jessica first tried not to believe what was happening. In all of their planning, they'd never considered that this could happen. Never before in the modern history of the US asylum system has the US sent political dissidents back to the country they fled without first allowing them to open asylum applications.
莫伊塞斯和杰西卡起初试图不相信正在发生的事情。在他们所有的计划中，他们从没考虑过这会发生。在美国庇护制度的现代史上，此前从未有过美国将政治异见者送回他们逃离的国家，而不允许他们开启庇护申请。
Yet there they were, being sent back to Nicaragua, delivered into the hands of their torturers. Police would be waiting for them at the airport. And they weren't alone. Dozens of Nicaraguan asylum seekers were herded onto a charter plane, destined for a country whose treatment of political prisoners, the State Department said, demonstrates the regime's utter disregard for human life and democratic freedoms.
然而他们就在那里，被送回尼加拉瓜，送到了折磨者手中。警察会在机场等着他们。而且他们并不孤单。几十名尼加拉瓜寻求庇护者被赶上一架包机，注定要前往一个国家，而这个国家对政治犯的处理方式，据国务院称，表现出该政权对人命和民主自由的彻底蔑视。
Not only is it a break from US policy going back decades, it's also a clear violation of international refugee law. I talked to people at the UN, and they were like, yeah, this is definitely illegal. US Customs and Border Protection did not respond to my request for comment. They claim that people seeking asylum still receive credible fear interviews, though I didn't find any evidence to support that.
这不仅是对美国几十年来政策的背离，也是对国际难民法的明显违规。我与联合国的人聊过，他们觉得是的，这绝对是非法的。美国海关及边境保护局没有回应我的置评请求。他们声称寻求庇护者仍会接受可信恐惧采访，尽管我没找到任何证据支持这一点。
The pilot comes on the intercom and calmly tells people to put their seatbelts on, like it's a normal flight. Meanwhile, the passengers are freaking out. They're still not completely sure where they're going.
飞行员通过对讲机平静地告诉人们系好安全带，就像正常的航班一样。与此同时，乘客们吓坏了。他们仍然不完全确定要去哪里。
Well, this time when we took off, the pilot said, well, the time expected to Nicaragua is three hours, something like that. And I say, oh my god, then we-- oh, now we're really going back, you know? It's, like, you feel unsecure, and you feel like there's nothing I can do. I cannot jump from the plane.
好吧，这次我们起飞时，飞行员说，预计到达尼加拉瓜的时间是三个小时，诸如此类。我说，噢我的天，那么我们……噢，现在我们真的要回去了，你知道吗？就好像，你感到不安全，你觉得我什么都做不了。我不能从飞机上跳下去。
The passengers were whispering to each other. "If they take me straight to prison, call my mom," one man said. "Whoever disappears, we should all assume he's in Chipote," said another. Moises recognized some of the other activists. He told me and my producer Nadia Reiman about it.
乘客们互相耳语。“如果他们直接把我带进监狱，给我妈打电话，”一个人说。“不管谁消失了，我们都应该假设他在奇波特，”另一个人说。莫伊塞斯认出了一些其他的活动人士。他告诉了我和我的制作人娜迪亚·雷曼这件事。
And everybody was in shackles. Everybody was in handcuffs. We were pretty sure. Oh, man, this is a-- I remember this movie Con Air. Everybody was running in the plane. Everybody was fighting with the officers about, I don't want to go back to Nicaragua. I don't want to be sent to Nicaragua. And--
每个人都被戴上了脚镣。每个人都戴着手铐。我们很确定。噢，伙计，这是个……我记得电影《空中监狱》。每个人都在飞机里跑来跑去。每个人都在和官员打架，说着，我不想回尼加拉瓜。我不想被送回尼加拉瓜。而且——
Wait, people are saying that on the plane?
等等，人们在飞机上那么说吗？
Yeah.
是的。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Camila was sitting beside the window, Moises beside the aisle. And I was in the middle because I'm afraid of flying. But I was so scared from the uncertainty from not knowing what was awaiting us that I wasn't even scared of flying. I told Moises that I couldn't even feel what the pilot was doing. I didn't even feel like I was flying on an airplane.
卡米拉坐在窗边，莫伊塞斯坐在过道旁。我坐在中间，因为我怕坐飞机。但我被这种不确定性吓坏了，因为不知道等待我们的是什么，以至于我甚至不怕坐飞机了。我告诉莫伊塞斯我甚至感觉不到飞行员在做什么。我甚至感觉不到我在乘飞机。
While they're mid-air, Moises realizes something-- the backpack. This bag full of evidence, he's about to land with it, and the police are going to see it. He can't think about anything else. The US immigration agents put it with the checked luggage, so it was somewhere in the belly of the plane. Moises couldn't even hold it, couldn't look at what was inside, and come up with a plan.
在飞行途中，莫伊塞斯意识到了一件事——那个背包。这个装满证据的包，他马上就要带着它着陆了，而警察会看到它。他脑子里什么都想不了了。美国移民官员把它放在了托运行李里，所以它在飞机的货舱里。莫伊塞斯甚至不能拿住它，不能看里面有什么，并想出一个计划。
If the police find it, they'll see that he listed the names of specific torturers and what they did to him. Maybe they would decide to kill him just for that. Maybe they rape his daughter, he thinks. His mind is spiraling out of control. Next to him, Jessica is busy trying to soothe Camila, feeding her Doritos.
如果警察发现它，他们会看到他列出了具体折磨者的名字和他们对他所做的事。也许他们会仅仅因为这个就决定杀了他。也许他们会强奸他的女儿，他想。他的大脑陷入了失控的螺旋。在他身边，杰西卡正忙着安抚卡米拉，给她喂多力多滋。
When we left, that backpack for me was the hope that I had, so I can make it to the US and apply for asylum. It was like my savior, my ticket to freedom. And when I was coming back to Nicaragua, it was the opposite. I was thinking, oh my god, that is the reason why they're going to shoot me or they're going to kill me. Because that's where I have all the evidence and the proof that I had. So the same backpack that was going to take me to freedom is the one that's going to kill me right now.
当我们离开时，那个背包对我来说是我拥有的希望，所以我可以去美国申请庇护。它就像我的救星，我通往自由的门票。而当我回到尼加拉瓜时，情况正好相反。我在想，噢我的天，这就是他们要开枪杀我或者杀我的原因。因为那里有我拥有的所有证据和证明。所以那个本该带我通往自由的背包，现在成了要我命的东西。
When the plane lands, Moises looks out the window at the fleet of Nicaraguan soldiers and police waiting for them. Everyone gets in line, walking down the steps of the plane. Moises and Jessica and all of the others are led into a garage-like office, where the government is conducting interrogations. They're patted down, their government IDs are confiscated. The whole time, Moises is thinking about his backpack.
飞机着陆时，莫伊塞斯看着窗外等待他们的尼加拉瓜士兵和警察车队。每个人排成一行，走下飞机台阶。莫伊塞斯、杰西卡和所有其他人被带进一个车库般的办公室，政府正在那里进行审讯。他们被搜身，政府身份证件被没收。全程，莫伊塞斯都在想着他的背包。
One officer snapped pictures of them. Another addressed them by name and asked what they were doing in the US and why they were deported. Moises tried to avoid answering. "They got me in Texas," he said, shrugging it off. They're led to another area full of police. Jessica and Camila walk hand-in-hand.
一名官员拍了他们的照片。另一名官员叫出了他们的名字，问他们在美国做什么，为什么被驱逐。莫伊塞斯试图避免回答。“他们是在得克萨斯抓到我的，”他耸耸肩说。他们被带到另一个满是警察的区域。杰西卡和卡米拉手牵手走着。
But Moises' eyes dart around, frantically searching for some sign of his backpack. Finally, he sees the luggage cart pull up, and there it is. Moises grabs his backpack and turns to face the wall of a building. It's the closest he can get to hiding. He reaches into the backpack and feels for the pages. He finds a statement, the document that outlines in explicit detail everything that happened to them.
但莫伊塞斯的眼睛四处乱转，疯狂地寻找背包的踪迹。最后，他看到行李车开过来，它在那里。莫伊塞斯抓住背包，转身面对建筑物的墙壁。这是他能做到的最接近隐藏的举动了。他伸进背包摸索那些纸张。他找到了一份声明，这份文件详细概述了发生在他们身上的一切。
And I knew that the first paper that I touched, I knew it was that statement. So when I noticed that they were not looking at me, I grabbed it and I put it in a fist, inside my fist. Then after that, I did it like I was wiping my face with the paper, like I was sweating because it was a lot of-- it was very hot when we got there. So I was sweating a lot.
我知道我摸到的第一张纸，我就知道那是那份声明。所以当我注意到他们没在看我时，我抓起它，握成拳头，握在拳头里。在那之后，我装作在用纸擦脸，就像我在出汗，因为我们到那里时非常热。所以我出汗很多。
So what I did is I made them think that I was using the paper to clean my sweat. Then when they were not looking, I was going to throw it in the trash can, actually. I thought about it. But I said, oh my god, I'm not going to throw it in the trash can. They might see me, or they might find it, you know? So what I did is the first thing that I thought, which was going to start eating it, real fast.
所以我做的是让他们以为我在用纸擦汗。然后当他们没看我时，我其实打算把它扔进垃圾桶。我考虑过。但我说，噢我的天，我不能把它扔进垃圾桶。他们可能会看见我，或者他们可能会发现它，你知道吗？所以我做的是我脑子里的第一反应，那就是开始吞下去，真的很快。
Oh my god.
噢我的天。
And it was wet because of the sweat, and so it was easy to swallow.
而且因为汗水，它是湿的，所以很容易吞咽。
Wait, so how many pages that you actually eat?
等等，那你到底吃了多少页纸？
There were five pages.
总共有五页。
How did you eat five pages of this paper?
你是怎么把这五页纸吃下去的？
I don't know, man. I think it was real scary. I just started swallowing. My wife says that I have a big mouth. I think that helped. So when I realized in a couple of seconds, I really had everything, and choking through my throat, so I started swallowing.
我不知道，伙计。我觉得当时太可怕了。我就开始吞咽。我妻子说我嘴大。我觉得那帮了忙。所以当我在几秒钟内意识到我真的把一切都吞了下去，并且卡在喉咙里时，我就开始吞咽了。
And what did the paper taste like?
那纸是什么味道的？
Well, because of the sweat, it was very, very salty. It was terrible.
嗯，因为汗水的缘故，它非常非常咸。糟透了。
As they walk through the crowd of police, he kept waiting for them to take him away. He kept waiting for them to open his bag. They never did. Instead, the police drove Moises, Jessica, and Camila to Jessica's mom's house in a patrol truck. When they got there, the police started taking more photos, like they were scouting a crime scene.
当他们走过警察人群时，他一直等着他们把他带走。他一直等着他们打开他的包。他们从来没打开过。相反，警察用巡逻车把莫伊塞斯、杰西卡和卡米拉送到了杰西卡妈妈家。当他们到那里时，警察开始拍更多的照片，就像在侦察犯罪现场一样。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
So when we got out, Camila was very skinny. Since we left, she had lost weight. So my mom didn't recognize her. When she saw the three of us, she didn't even recognize us. We got out of the van, and they said, "We're going to hand over your family members now, and we'd like to take a picture so that there's evidence that the people who were deported were handed to their family members."
所以当我们出来时，卡米拉非常瘦。自从我们离开，她就瘦了。所以连我妈妈都没认出她。当她看到我们三个时，她甚至没认出我们。我们从货车上下来，他们说，“我们现在要移交你们的家人了，我们想拍张照，这样就有证据表明被驱逐的人已经移交给了他们的家人。”
This is how Nicaragua's para-police often work. They make note of where you live, and when they want to, they go after you. Moises and Jessica had to figure out what to do next. After a few days, they noticed that the police were circling the house. The police called it random and asked about Camila.
这就是尼加拉瓜准警察通常的运作方式。他们记下你住的地方，当他们想的时候，他们就会找上门。莫伊塞斯和杰西卡不得不考虑下一步怎么做。几天后，他们注意到警察在围着房子转。警察称这只是随机的，还问起了卡米拉。
Staying at a known address was too dangerous. They didn't think the police would hurt Camila, but what if they came for Moises or Jessica while Camila was there? She could be swept up in the violence. So Moises and Jessica relocated to the attic of a safe house and left Camila. They told her, "We'll see you soon," but truthfully, they had no idea when.
住在已知的住址太危险了。他们认为警察不会伤害卡米拉，但如果他们因为莫伊塞斯或杰西卡而去呢，而卡米拉当时也在？她会被卷进暴力事件中。所以莫伊塞斯和杰西卡搬到了安全屋的阁楼，留下了卡米拉。他们告诉她：“我们会很快见面的，”但说实话，他们根本不知道什么时候。
It was brutal to say goodbye, but what was the alternative, they thought. If Camila was attacked on their behalf, that would be much worse. Jessica cried when she said goodbye. That was about two months ago. She's cried most days since.
说再见太残酷了，但他们想，还有别的选择吗？如果卡米拉因为他们而受到攻击，那会糟糕得多。杰西卡说再见时哭了。那是大约两个月前的事。从那以后，她几乎每天都在哭。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I still do. I still feel guilty. We're in hiding. I can't always see my daughter. And I can't keep every promise that I made. I feel like I failed as a mother.
我还是会哭。我依然感到内疚。我们在躲藏。我不能总是见到我的女儿。我不能信守我做出的每一个承诺。我觉得我作为一个母亲失败了。
Their days are now about hiding. They spent weeks in the attic, sleeping on the floor. And now they're a floor below in a tiny, mostly empty bedroom. But they're still just as afraid of being found. The landlord warns them when someone is downstairs so they can remain extra quiet. When one of them drops something or accidentally makes a loud noise, they're like, did anyone hear that? Is that the thing that's going to give us away?
他们现在的日子就是关于躲藏。他们在阁楼里住了几周，睡在地板上。现在他们住在下一层一个极小、几乎空无一物的卧室里。但他们仍然同样害怕被发现。当楼下有人时，房东会提醒他们，好让他们保持额外的安静。当他们中的一个掉东西或不小心发出巨大的声音时，他们就会想，有人听到了吗？这就是会让我们暴露的事情吗？
Sometimes, Jessica wakes up and, for an instant, has no idea where she is. She has to remind herself, I'm back in Nicaragua. I'm in hiding in my own country. They're back where they were a year ago, asking the same questions. Should we leave? And when? This time, the answers are harder to agree on.
有时，杰西卡醒来，一瞬间根本不知道自己在哪里。她不得不提醒自己，我在尼加拉瓜。我在自己的国家躲藏。他们又回到了去年的地方，问同样的问题。我们要离开吗？什么时候？这一次，很难达成一致的答案。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Sometimes, we have very intense arguments because, right now, we don't know what's going to happen. We don't know how long things are going to be like this. It's like being in jail without the torture. But I think there is torture psychologically, emotionally, because you can't be near the people you love.
有时，我们会有非常激烈的争论，因为现在，我们不知道会发生什么。我们不知道这样的日子还要持续多久。这就像在没有酷刑的情况下坐牢。但我认为在心理上、情感上是有酷刑的，因为你不能靠近你爱的人。
How many times a day do you think about what you're going to do, about your plans for what to do next?
你一天想多少次你接下来要做什么，关于你下一步的计划？
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I think up until a few days ago, it was up to 20 hours a day. But I've decided that I need to wait. One day this month, Moises made it very clear that the door was closed, that we just needed to wait for the door to open, that we just needed to have patience because I don't know what else we can do. We can't think about leaving if we don't have the economic means. But we can't think about staying here because I don't know how much longer we can.
我想直到几天前，大概每天20个小时。但我决定我需要等待。这个月的一天，莫伊塞斯非常明确地表示门已经关上了，我们只需要等待门打开，我们只需要耐心，因为我不知道我们还能做什么。如果我们没有经济手段，我们就不能考虑离开。但我们不能考虑待在这里，因为我不知道我们还能坚持多久。
Most of the people arriving at the US border these days know that the asylum system has been whittled away. Like Moises and Jessica, they knew it wasn't going to be easy, that it could take years.
如今大部分到达美国边境的人都知道庇护系统已经被削减了。像莫伊塞斯和杰西卡一样，他们知道这不会容易，可能需要几年时间。
But they believed in their case. That pile of papers in Moises' backpack-- anyone who saw them would be convinced, they thought. What they didn't believe-- and why would they-- was that no one would even look and that the backpack would end up back in a safe house next to Moises' head when he sleeps. Everything's still inside the way it was when they left for the first time.
但他们相信自己的案子。莫伊塞斯背包里的那一堆文件——他们想，任何看到这些的人都会被说服。他们不相信的是——为什么会相信呢——竟然没人看一眼，而这个背包最后会回到莫伊塞斯睡觉时枕头旁的那个安全屋里。一切还在里面，就像他们第一次离开时那样。
Kevin Sieff is the Mexico and Central America Bureau chief for The Washington Post. A version of this story appeared in The Washington Post and in their daily podcast, Post Reports.
凯文·西夫是《华盛顿邮报》墨西哥和中美洲分社社长。这个故事的一个版本出现在《华盛顿邮报》及其每日播客《邮报报道》中。
Coming up, people who work in a field where it is really hard to find a good, steady job. These people find one, and then the only problem is, they have to actually come in and do the job every day, exactly the way they did it the day before. And I mean, like, exactly the way they did it. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，是那些在一个很难找到一份好而稳定的工作领域工作的人们。这些人找到了工作，然后唯一的问题是，他们必须每天都来上班，像前一天做的那样。我是说，就像他们前一天做的那样。芝加哥公共广播电台将在我们的节目继续后，一分钟后带来这个故事。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Walls Close In, stories of people trapped in small spaces and what that's like. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Music of the Night After Night After Night After Night After Night After Night After Night After Night-- [FADES AWAY]
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，墙壁围拢，讲述那些被困在狭小空间里的人们以及那样的生活是什么样的。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，夜复一夜又一夜又一夜又一夜又一夜又一夜又一夜的音乐—— [声音渐弱]
We now turn to people who've made a choice, a conscious choice to stick themselves into a cramped, uncomfortable space for years inside the theater. You know, the old saying "hell is other people" actually comes from the theater. It comes from a play, No Exit. That play was not written by a member of a theater orchestra. But Jay Caspian Kang has this story about how many musicians in theatrical orchestras might understand the sentiment.
我们现在转向那些做出选择的人，一个自觉的选择，把他们自己塞进一个局促、不舒服的空间里，几年之久，在剧院里。你知道，那句老话“他人即地狱”实际上出自戏剧。出自一部戏剧，《禁闭》。那部剧不是剧院管弦乐队的成员写的。但杰·卡斯皮安·康（Jay Caspian Kang）带来了一个故事，关于多少剧院管弦乐队的音乐家们可能理解这种感受。
Nick Jemo moved to New York in 2006 to try to make it as a musician. He had just finished up college and had all these dreams of playing the trumpet for a living. But it was a struggle. There just aren't many jobs for trumpet players anymore.
尼克·杰莫（Nick Jemo）2006年搬到纽约试图成为一名音乐家。他刚大学毕业，怀揣着靠吹小号谋生的梦想。但这很挣扎。现在小号手的职位真的不多了。
So he mostly waited by the phone for gigs. Korean megachurch services, experimental plays, and the occasional substitute job with Mary Poppins on Broadway. And then a spot opened up at his favorite show.
所以他大多在电话旁等着活。韩国大型教会的礼拜、实验剧，以及偶尔在百老汇《欢乐满人间》的替补工作。然后他最喜欢的节目出现了一个名额。
This might be TMI, but I remember I was in my apartment. I was on the toilet. And [CHUCKLING] I got a phone call, and I didn't recognize the number. And I listened to the voicemail, saying, "Hi, this is Kristen," and freaked out.
这可能说得太多了，但我记得当时我在公寓里。我在厕所里。然后 [轻笑] 我接到了一个电话，我不认识那个号码。我听了语音留言，说：“嘿，我是克里斯汀，”我惊呆了。
This was one of the conductors for Phantom of the Opera. She offered him a job playing shows six days a week and twice on Thursdays and Saturdays.
这是《歌剧魅影》的指挥之一。她提供给他一份工作，每周六天，周四和周六还要演两场。
I'm not sure I probably even let her finish her sentence. Yes, I'm very interested and available. It was life changing, really.
我不确定我是否让她把话讲完。是的，我很有兴趣，也有空。这真的是改变人生。
Did you feel you'd like won the lottery?
你觉得你就像中了彩票吗？
Oh, yes. Actually, I remember the next day, I had to go grocery shopping. And I remember buying coconut water. I don't know why. That was my treat because I always wanted to buy coconut water, but it was always too much of a-- it was like, you know what? This is-- I just don't need to spend. And I remember buying coconut water and feeling like such a badass. And I just felt like I can buy anything here.
噢，是的。实际上，我记得第二天，我得去买杂货。我记得我买了椰子水。我不知道为什么。那是我的奖励，因为我一直想买椰子水，但总是太贵——就像，你知道吗？这是——我不需要花钱。我记得我买了椰子水，感觉像个硬汉。我当时觉得我在这里什么都买得起。
It wasn't just a steady income Nick was excited about. Phantom of the Opera was the show Nick had loved since he was 11 years old. He had just started playing the trumpet and would lay on his living room floor listening to The Music of the Night. You know it-- (SINGING) "Slowly, gently, night unfurls its splendor."
尼克兴奋的不仅仅是稳定的收入。《歌剧魅影》是尼克从11岁起就一直喜爱的剧。他刚开始学吹小号，会躺在客厅的地板上听《夜之乐章》。你知道那段——（唱）“慢慢地，温柔地，黑夜舒展它的光辉。”
That call changed his life. He had finally arrived, Phantom on Broadway. On his first day, Nick entered the majestic theater on 46th and 8th Avenue. He walked through a back alley, past a giant tub of dry ice, down a flight of stairs into a locker room where he changed into all black. He then headed into the pit to play the music he had loved as a child. He had his own seat there now and a music stand.
那个电话改变了他的人生。他终于到了，百老汇的《魅影》。第一天，尼克走进位于第46街和第8大道的雄伟剧院。他穿过一条后巷，经过一个巨大的干冰桶，走下一段楼梯进入更衣室，换上一身全黑的衣服。然后他进入乐池演奏他小时候喜爱的音乐。他在那里有了自己的座位和一个谱架。
So he played the first show. Next day, he went back and played it again, and then again. His brain started to adjust to playing the same show eight times a week. And then he started to notice, it wasn't just the music that repeated itself.
所以他演了第一场。第二天，他又回去演了一次，然后又是下一次。他的大脑开始适应每周演八次同样的节目。然后他开始注意到，不断重复的不仅仅是音乐。
I'm seeing the same actors in the exact same time and the same musicians at the exact same time, and seeing the same people in the bathroom at the exact same time. [LAUGHS] Every time one of the dancers comes through to put her wig on, she says to one of the other dancers, "Good job, Erica," like, every single day. It's very Groundhog Day.
我每天在完全相同的时间看到完全相同的演员和完全相同的音乐家，在完全相同的时间看到洗手间里的同一些人。[笑声] 每次其中一个舞者经过来戴她的假发时，她都会对另一个舞者说，“做得好，艾瑞卡，”就像每天一样。这非常像《土拨鼠之日》。
At first, this was funny, almost charming. Nick was 30 and the youngest person in the pit. Not by a few years, but by a few decades. He'd never been in a situation like this where everyone seemed so locked into routine. His colleagues would sit down in their chairs at the exact same minute every day.
起初，这很有趣，甚至很迷人。尼克当时30岁，是乐池里最年轻的人。不是小几岁，而是小几十岁。他从没处于过这样一个境地，每个人似乎都深深地陷入了日常琐事中。他的同事们每天都会在完全相同的一分钟坐在椅子上。
There was the cellist who would say, "Marvelous," every time Nick asked him how he was doing. There was the first horn player who would pull out a stopwatch every single night to time how long the second horn player held the note in one of the songs. Some days it would be 17 seconds, other days 16.2.
那个大提琴手每次尼克问他过得怎么样时都会说“太棒了”。那个第一圆号手每天晚上都会掏出秒表计时第二圆号手在其中一首歌里长音拖了多久。有时候是17秒，有时候是16.2秒。
You definitely start to notice, people are talking about each other and complaining about the same people are late every single week. If you bump into a stand by accident, you'll get a "what the [MUTED] are you doing" kind of look. Like, [INHALES] take a deep breath, you know? Like, [EXHALES]
你绝对会开始注意到，人们在谈论彼此，抱怨同一些人每周迟到。如果你不小心撞到了谱架，你会得到一个“你他妈在干什么”的眼神。就像，[吸气] 深呼吸，你知道吗？就像，[呼气]
What is it like being the youngest guy there, the young guy?
作为那里最年轻的家伙，那是什么感觉，年轻的小伙？
Basically, I'm not as jaded as the rest of them. If I say anything that's not like, [SIGHS] "It sucks to be here," they're like, "You haven't been here long enough. You're still new. You're still new." People kind of walk in there, like, [SIGHS] OK, I've got to do this again. And some of it's just in their body language, the way they walk in the door. They're kind of trudging in. Or when someone says, "Do I have to do this tonight?"
基本上，我没有他们那么厌倦。如果我说任何不像 [叹气] “待在这真糟糕”的话，他们就会说，“你待在这里的时间还不够长。你还是新人。你还是新人。”人们走进那里时，就像 [叹气] 好吧，我得再做一遍。有些只是体现在他们的身体语言上，他们走进门口的方式。他们像是蹒跚而行。或者当有人说，“我今晚非得做这个吗？”
Phantom of the Opera opened on Broadway in January 1988. It was an instant hit.
《歌剧魅影》于1988年1月在百老汇首演。它立刻大获成功。
Everyone who has seen this musical comes away enchanted.
每一个看过这部音乐剧的人都感到着迷。
The show is virtually guaranteed to run well into the next decade.
这部剧几乎可以肯定会持续到下一个十年。
It did. And then another decade. And another. The musicians in the pit signed contracts with a provision which guaranteed their jobs until the show shut down. They expected two, maybe three years. But the show kept going, as three years turned into five years, which then turned into 32. That's over 13,000 performances.
它确实做到了。然后是又一个十年。又一个。乐池里的音乐家们签了合同，附带条款保证他们的工作直到演出结束。他们预计是两年，也许三年。但演出一直持续，三年变成了五年，然后变成了32年。那是超过13000场演出。
Phantom is now the longest running show in the history of Broadway.
《魅影》现在是百老汇历史上演出时间最长的节目。
There is almost a feeling, I think, of nausea that you have to do it again and you have to do it again.
我觉得甚至有一种恶心的感觉，就是你必须再做一遍，你必须再做一遍。
That's Melanie Feld, an oboist who's been in the pit for 28 years now.
那是梅兰妮·费尔德（Melanie Feld），一位已经在乐池里待了28年的双簧管演奏家。
I don't know how to describe it-- a physical sensation that I get of literally that I'm jumping out of my skin. It's a leg thing. I can't stay in my skin. I'm going crazy. Oh, no, that thing is happening.
我不知道该怎么描述——我得到的一种身体感觉，字面意思上，我想从自己的皮肤里跳出来。那是腿的问题。我没法待在自己的皮里。我要疯了。噢不，那件事又发生了。
I first heard about the pit at Phantom through a friend whose wife had recently subbed in the violin section. She described what she had seen as a horror show, like Waiting for Guffman, but 30 hard years down the line. I couldn't quite get it out of my head.
我第一次听说《魅影》的乐池是通过一个朋友，他的妻子最近替补了小提琴组。她把她看到的一切描述成恐怖表演，就像《等待古夫曼》，但那是30年艰难岁月的积累。我怎么也忘不了这个场景。
So one of the first things people ask, how can you possibly stay sane and play the same music every night?
所以人们问的第一件事就是，你怎么可能保持理智，每天晚上演奏同样的音乐？
Pete Reit has been playing Phantom since opening night. He's the French horn player who times the notes on a stopwatch every night.
皮特·赖特（Pete Reit）从开演之夜起就一直在演奏《魅影》。他就是那个每天晚上用秒表计时长音的圆号手。
There is something in that where I would look at the music sometimes, and it would just literally look like shapes. I would just see circles and lines and dots. And I would have no idea. I wouldn't even know what page I was on.
这其中确实有一些东西，我会盯着乐谱看，它看起来就纯粹是形状。我只会看到圆圈、线条和点点。我完全不知道。我甚至不知道我在哪一页。
It's like a disassociative feeling, almost.
这就像是一种解离感，几乎是。
It's sort of like hearing yourself speak, and you aren't sure it's English.
这有点像听你自己说话，你不确定那是英语。
[LAUGHS] Well, I don't think that's ever happened to me, Pete.
[笑声] 嗯，我不认为那发生在我身上过，皮特。
And then the funny thing is, you see someone else do it, and you immediately know what's going on with them.
然后有趣的是，你看到别人这样做，你会立刻知道他们发生了什么。
What does their face look like?
他们的脸看起来是什么样的？
Oh, they're just-- it's as if they don't even know where they are. They're, like, waking up in another room. It's like, what happened? Where am I? What day is it? What week is it?
噢，他们只是——就好像他们甚至不知道自己在哪里。他们像是，在另一个房间醒来。就像，发生了什么？我在哪？今天是星期几？这是哪一周？
When I started talking to the pit musicians a couple of years ago, I wanted to know how they found meaning in the mundane and inevitable repetitions of life. In lots of jobs, people do the same thing every day, but nothing quite like this.
几年前我开始与乐池音乐家们交谈时，我想知道他们是如何在平凡且不可避免的生活重复中找到意义的。在很多工作中，人们每天做同样的事情，但没有像这样完全一样的。
You're hearing the exact same lines from the stage, playing the exact same notes for the same songs. Even the guy sitting next to you breathes in the exact same rhythm. Every day, the Phantom kisses Christine for the first time, and the same chandelier comes crashing down in the same spot on the stage.
你从舞台上听到完全相同的台词，为同样的歌演奏完全相同的音符。甚至坐在你旁边的那个人呼吸的节奏也完全一样。每一天，魅影第一次亲吻克里斯汀，同一盏吊灯都在舞台上的同一个地方摔得粉碎。
I assumed the orchestra members were like Zen archers who pull back the same bow with the same motion until they die. I talked to a trumpet player named Lowell Hershey. Lowell has been at the show since day one, and everyone says he's the sanest person in the pit.
我以为管弦乐队成员就像禅宗射手，他们以同样的动作拉开同样的弓，直到死去。我采访了一位名叫洛厄尔·赫尔希（Lowell Hershey）的小号手。洛厄尔从第一天起就在剧组，每个人都说他是乐池里最理智的人。
And it kind of drives you nuts for the first few weeks. And then after that, your mind deals with it and just flushes it out. So when you're not there, you don't think about it.
在最初的几周里，它确实会让你发疯。然后在那之后，你的大脑会处理它，直接把它冲刷掉。所以当你不在那里时，你根本不会去想它。
Do you know the words to the songs that you're playing?
你知道你演奏的那些歌的歌词吗？
No, not entirely.
不，不完全知道。
"Where in the world--"
“世上何处——”
"Think of me fondly--" whatever. I mean, I remember one time after the show had been running for a while, somebody asked me to play a little bit of a tune from the show, and I couldn't even do it. I couldn't even think of one. I had submerged this much.
“深情地想我——”之类的。我的意思是，我记得有一次演出运行了一段时间后，有人让我演奏一点节目里的曲子，我甚至做不到。我甚至连一首也想不起来。我沉浸得太深了。
I feel like your brain has basically just rejected being cognizant that the music is going on.
我觉得你的大脑基本上拒绝意识到音乐正在进行。
But I think that's typical of people who do shows.
但我认为这对做演出的人来说很典型。
What do you think the right type of personality is that can handle this job?
你认为什么样的性格适合这份工作？
I'm descended from a long line of serfs and peons, people who are still laboring in the fields for hardly any money and are relatively happy with that.
我出身于一长串农奴和苦力的后代，那些仍然在田里劳动，拿很少的钱，却对那相对感到满意的人们。
The Phantom players aren't exactly serfs. They're well-paid, they play a beloved show, and they get to play in small orchestras on the side. But these are highly-trained musicians who went to the fanciest music schools in the world.
《魅影》的演奏者们不完全是农奴。他们薪水高，演奏一部受人喜爱的剧，还能在业余时间在小型管弦乐队演奏。但这些都是受过高等训练的音乐家，他们去了世界上最好的音乐学校。
Andrew Lloyd Weber wanted the best of the best for Phantom, which means the pit will always sound good, though it also creates some creative and spiritual problems for the players, who have to get through the score night after night after night.
安德鲁·劳埃德·韦伯想要为《魅影》挑选最好的，这意味着乐池听起来总是很好，尽管这也给演奏者们带来了一些创作和精神上的问题，他们必须在每一夜每一夜的演奏中熬过乐谱。
I'm a violin operator.
我是小提琴操作员。
Is that how you describe that?
你是这么描述它的吗？
That's how we describe it, yeah. It's very technical. I have no emotional connection with it.
我们就是这么描述的，是的。非常技术性。我跟它没有任何情感联系。
That's a violinist named Kurt Coble. He's a composer. His dream was always to write scores for horror films. He's now been at Phantom for 22 years, long enough to see three people in his section die.
那是名叫库尔特·科布尔（Kurt Coble）的小提琴手。他是位作曲家。他的梦想一直是为恐怖电影写配乐。他现在在《魅影》待了22年，久到见证了他的小组里三个人去世。
When I'm playing the show, nobody's interested in my creative input. I've often compared it to working in a hospice. It's just, we just keep the show alive as long as we can.
当我在演奏时，没人对我的创作投入感兴趣。我经常把它比作在临终关怀中心工作。我们只是尽可能让这个节目活得久一点。
So here they all are, in this weird social experiment, trapped together for decades, 27 musicians crammed into this tiny space. A trumpet player told me it's like playing in a submarine.
所以他们都在这里，在这个奇怪的社会实验中，几十年里挤在一起，27名音乐家挤在这个小空间里。一个小号手告诉我，这就像在潜艇里演奏。
I've been down there, and you can barely turn around without knocking into something. In the pit, you notice everything-- the way your neighbor blows out his spit valve, the way someone brags about their kids, the smell of someone's perfume. Every little annoyance, every perceived slight accumulates.
我在下面待过，你几乎无法转过身而不撞到东西。在乐池里，你会注意到一切——你的邻居吹出口水阀的方式，某人吹嘘他们孩子的方式，某人香水的味道。每一个小烦恼，每一个被察觉的怠慢都会积累。
One of my favorite stories, which should drive anyone who has ever played in a band crazy-- there's this bassoon player who has sat next to the same clarinet player since 1988. She's convinced he plays half a note flat on every note he's ever played. He denies this.
我最喜欢的故事之一，这应该会让任何在乐队里待过的人发疯——有一位巴松管手自1988年起就一直坐在同一个单簧管手旁边。她确信他吹的每一个音都比标准音低半个音。他否认这一点。
The person I talked to the most in the pit was Melanie, the oboist. She's one of the rare people you meet who has no real filter.
我在乐池里聊得最多的是梅兰妮，那位双簧管演奏家。她是那种你遇到的极少数完全不掩饰的人之一。
So I was complaining about something, which I imagine was that it was really cold. It's always really cold. And then someone else from the orchestra said, [SIGHS] I'm just so tired of the sound of your voice. You know, and I'm tired of the sound of my voice, too. So I kind of sympathize with her.
当时我在抱怨什么东西，我猜是真的很冷。总是真的很冷。然后管弦乐队里的另一个人说，[叹气] 我实在受够了你的声音。你知道吗，我也受够了我自己的声音。所以我多少同情她。
Then there was a violinist who got mad at me because I said I used Roundup in my garden. She was like, [HUFFS] and she wouldn't speak to me for-- I don't know-- weeks.
还有一个小提琴手因为我说我在花园里用了农达（除草剂）而生我的气。她当时就像，[哼] 她有——我不知道——几周没跟我说话。
During most of our talks, Melanie was making reeds. It's an extraordinarily meticulous process. There's all sorts of medieval-looking tools and tiny bits of wood everywhere.
在我们的大部分谈话中，梅兰妮都在制作簧片。这是一个极其严谨的过程。到处都是各种中世纪样子的工具和细小的木头。
Oboists are the most optimistic people in the world because every time they make a reed, they think that it might work. They usually don't, but anyway. This part-- oh, no, I'm skipping the most important part. You need to pick your color of thread! And it just makes all the difference. And I never know what color to pick. But this is the only fun that I have, so.
双簧管演奏家是世界上最乐观的人，因为每次他们制作一个簧片，他们都认为它可能会成功。他们通常不会，但无论如何。这一部分——噢，不，我漏掉了最重要的部分。你需要选择你的线色！那真的有很大不同。我从不知道该选什么颜色。但这是我仅有的乐趣，所以。
[HIGH PITCH REED]
[高音簧片声]
That god awful noise.
那个糟糕透顶的声音。
Melanie studied at Juilliard. She dreamed of being the principal oboist in the Metropolitan Opera or the Philharmonic. But she kept bombing her auditions. Her nerves got the best of her every time she was up for a big seat. And then life and bills intervened.
梅兰妮在朱莉亚音乐学院学习过。她梦想着成为大都会歌剧院或爱乐乐团的首席双簧管演奏家。但她每次试演都搞砸了。每次争取大席位时，她的紧张都击败了她。然后生活和账单介入了。
Phantom, in that way, is a very good job in a field where there aren't a lot of good jobs anymore. It put Melanie's kids through college, paid her mortgage, and provided security while the music industry collapsed around her. But at the end of 30 years sitting just inches away from your co-workers, you lose all sense of proportion. Your enemies turn into monsters.
从这个角度看，《魅影》是一份非常好的工作，而在一个好工作不再多的领域里，它让梅兰妮的孩子读完了大学，付了抵押贷款，并在音乐产业崩溃时提供了安全保障。但在距离同事只有几英寸的地方坐了30年后，你失去了所有的比例感。你的敌人变成了怪物。
For Melanie, the monster in the pit was always a trumpet player named Francis Bonny. Everything he did drove Melanie nuts, from the black biking shorts he wore in the pit to always eating his dinner in the locker room with his back turned to her.
对于梅兰妮来说，乐池里的怪物一直是一位名叫弗朗西斯·邦尼（Francis Bonny）的小号手。他做的一切都让梅兰妮抓狂，从他在乐池里穿的黑色骑行短裤，到总是在更衣室里背对着她吃晚餐。
Francis was a miserable son of a bitch. And at a certain point, he started wearing-- he put this black shade on the side of his glasses. And he's wearing those things because he doesn't want to see me, right? That's why he's wear-- I really truly believe this.
弗朗西斯是个可怜的混蛋。在某个时间点，他开始佩戴——他把这个黑色遮光罩戴在他的眼镜边上。他戴着那些东西是因为他不想看到我，对吧？这就是他戴着——我真的真心相信这一点。
I wanted to run this all by Francis. It just seemed so unreasonable. Francis was the only person I had talked to who had actually escaped from the pit. He got in a truck and drove out to the middle of nowhere in Colorado. He says he's much happier now.
我想把这一切都告诉弗朗西斯。这看起来太不合理了。弗朗西斯是我谈过的唯一一个真正从乐池逃脱的人。他跳上一辆卡车，开车去了科罗拉多州荒无人烟的地方。他说他现在快乐多了。
You spoke with Melanie! Oh!
你跟梅兰妮聊过！噢！
Yeah, yeah, we did. I understand that you two did not have the best relationship. One of the things that she told us was that you basically made an eyepatch so that you wouldn't have to look at her. Is this a true story that she's telling us?
是的，是的，聊过。据我所知，你们俩的关系不太好。她告诉我们的一件事是，你基本上做了一个眼罩，这样你就不用看她了。这是她在讲的一个真实故事吗？
I did do that at some point. But that wasn't just because of Melanie. She's taking it too personally. It was actually anybody that was on my right. [LAUGHS]
我确实在某个时候那么做过。但这不仅仅是因为梅兰妮。她把它个人化了。其实这是对我右边的任何人。[笑声]
She told us for a long time that you sat in the locker room and that you would turn your back to everybody because you didn't want to look at them.
她告诉我们，很长一段时间你坐在更衣室里，而且你会转过身背对着每个人，因为你不想看他们。
Yeah, yeah, it was in the locker room. I came there, I ate my dinner. Looked at the white wall, went and played the show, and then left the theater. Left the premises as fast as I could, and it worked beautifully.
是的，是的，那是在更衣室里。我到那，吃我的晚餐。盯着白墙，去演奏节目，然后离开剧院。尽快离开现场，它运作得非常完美。
Can you compare the relationships that you have with other relationships?
你能把你们拥有的关系与其他关系进行比较吗？
It's family. [LAUGHS] It's the spouse you can't stand and putting up with people that you just don't want to hear their voice again. You sit there thousands and thousands and thousands and thousands of hours. This is like a quarter of a lifetime.
这是家人。[笑声] 这是你忍受不了的配偶，并且还要忍受那些你不想再听到他们声音的人。你坐在那里成千上万个小时。这就像是四分之一个生命。
The musicians in the pit don't play the whole time, which means there are thousands of hours where they're not actually doing anything. And during those rests, they read books, spy thrillers and mysteries, and do the crossword with their neighbors. A trumpet player has taught himself three languages. Another musician ran a woodshop business on his laptop during the show.
乐池里的音乐家们并不是一直都在演奏，这意味着有成千上万个小时他们什么也没做。在休息期间，他们阅读书籍、间谍惊悚片和悬疑小说，并和邻座的人一起做填字游戏。一位小号手自学了三种语言。另一位音乐家在演出期间在笔记本电脑上经营一家木工生意。
And socially, it's a bit like middle school. There are the loners, the jocks, and the French horns. They're like the boys in the back of the bus. They bring in fart machines and run the same practical jokes over and over. Sometimes they even mess with the audience. The front row is right up against the pit, so close that their feet sometimes dangle next to the musicians heads. Occasionally, one of the French horn players would take out a bottle of whiteout and write little messages on the soles of the audience's shoes.
在社交上，它有点像中学。有独行侠、体育生和圆号手。他们就像坐在车后座的男孩们。他们带进屁声机，一遍又一遍地玩同样的恶作剧。有时他们甚至会戏弄观众。第一排就在乐池边上，距离非常近，他们的脚有时会悬在音乐家们的头顶旁边。偶尔，其中一名圆号手会拿出一瓶修正液，在观众鞋底写上小消息。
Those guys, they're sitting right behind me. They're always chattering and laughing. I, being me, if I play badly, I think, oh, god, they're saying how terrible I am. Oh, god, I don't want to humiliate myself.
那些家伙，他们就坐在我后面。他们总是喋喋不休，大笑。我，像我这样的人，如果我演得糟糕，我会想，噢，天哪，他们肯定在说我有多糟糕。噢，天哪，我不想让自己出丑。
This, more than anything, Melanie told me, is what makes her want to sound good every night. She's worried the French horn guys will make fun of her.
比起其他任何事情，梅兰妮告诉我，这就是让她每天晚上都想演得好的原因。她担心圆号手们会取笑她。
I'm not playing for the audience because the audience doesn't-- and so I'm playing for those French horn players. I do want to say, one of the compliments I've gotten over the years is, how do you still play so well when you've just been doing Phantom for all those years? I said it's is a choice that I've made. My choice is to play this music like it's any other music that I play and make it beautiful.
我不是为了观众而演奏，因为观众并不——所以我为那些圆号手们演奏。我确实想说，多年来我得到的赞美之一是，你做了这么多年的《魅影》，怎么还能演得这么好？我说这是我做出的一个选择。我的选择是像演奏其他音乐一样演奏它，并使它变得优美。
Can you just play something from Phantom?
你能随便演一点《魅影》吗？
Well, I can play the really hard one. If it's really bad, though, I beg you not to--
好吧，我可以演那段真的很难的。如果真的很糟糕，我请求你不要——
[PLAYS OBOE]
[演奏双簧管]
Nobody is in the Phantom pit right now. The show temporarily closed in March because of COVID-19. The unstoppable show had finally been put on pause. I recently checked in with Melanie again. She wasn't doing very well. Her mother had died in a nursing home in New Jersey, presumed COVID-positive. She wasn't getting paid by the show anymore. And she missed Phantom.
现在没有人待在《魅影》的乐池里。由于新冠疫情，演出在3月暂时关闭了。这部不可阻挡的剧最终被迫暂停。我最近又查了梅兰妮的情况。她过得不太好。她的母亲在新泽西州的一家疗养院去世了，推测是新冠阳性。她不再从演出中领薪水了。她想念《魅影》。
This was surprising to me. Melanie and all the other musicians had told me about their fantasies of finally leaving the show. And I had believed them. But now that it had actually happened, she missed the routine.
这让我感到吃惊。梅兰妮和其他所有音乐家之前都告诉我他们最终离开演出的幻想。我也相信他们。但现在这真的发生了，她却想念那个日常工作。
You know, Phantom, I miss the comradeship, the repetition of the silly jokes and watching everyone eat and-- I don't know-- the routine. I kind of like routine in my life.
你知道，《魅影》，我想念那种友谊，那些傻笑话的重复，看着每个人吃东西，还有——我不知道——那种日常。我有点喜欢生活中的日常。
This, of course, is the opposite of what she'd said in the past, before COVID.
这当然和她在新冠疫情前所说的完全相反。
It was always easy to complain that it was boring, and to complain about driving into the city, and wasting all that time in the car, and playing the same music and going home again. And I just thought, I knew I was lucky back then, but it becomes very real now. I mean, what can I say?
抱怨它无聊总是很容易，抱怨开车进城、浪费在车里的所有时间、演奏同样的音乐、然后又回家，总是很容易。我当时就知道我很幸运，但现在它变得非常真实。我的意思是，我能说什么呢？
Now I really know what it's like not having this job. It's just so much fun to complain about things that don't matter. Oh, the women in the bathroom, they're just always talking about their expensive hair and makeup. And I miss the women in the bathroom. And yeah, I'd be happy to complain about that again.
现在我真的知道没有这份工作是什么感觉了。抱怨那些无关紧要的事情太有趣了。噢，洗手间的女人们，她们总是谈论她们昂贵的头发和妆容。我想念洗手间的女人们。是的，我很乐意再次抱怨这些。
Before the pandemic, every time I talked to Melanie, I would ask how she was doing. Her answer always depended on parking. It's hard to park in midtown Manhattan. A good parking spot was a good day. A bad parking spot was a bad day. This is how she made sense of her life.
疫情前，每次我和梅兰妮谈话，我都会问她过得怎么样。她的回答总是取决于停车位。在曼哈顿中城停车很难。一个好的停车位就是美好的一天。一个糟糕的停车位就是糟糕的一天。这就是她理解生活的方式。
I think about this all the time. Most of our lives are spent finding parking for the job we don't want to do. Melanie is not alone in that. And after any number of years, those routines accumulate. And that's more or less your life.
我一直都在想这个。我们大部分的生活都花在为我们不想做的工作寻找停车位上。梅兰妮在这点上并不孤单。在经历了若干年后，那些日常工作堆积起来了。那或多或少就是你的人生。
Of all the people I talked to in the pit, one musician dealt with the mundane and inevitable repetition of life in a way that really stuck with me. For the past two decades in the pit, Kurt, the musician who described himself as a violin operator, had been dreaming up the most elaborate and metaphorically perfect coping mechanism. It's a band made up entirely of automatons. I met these robot musicians in a warehouse in Yonkers.
在乐池里我谈过的所有人中，有一位音乐家处理平凡且不可避免的生活重复的方式真的打动了我。过去二十年里在乐池中，把自己描述为小提琴操作员的库尔特，一直梦想着最复杂且在比喻上完美的应对机制。这是一个完全由自动化机器组成的乐队。我在扬克斯的一个仓库里见到了这些机器人音乐家。
The PAM Band!
PAM乐队！
The PAM Band stands for Partially Artificial Musicians. Kurt's automatons are made up of scraps of metal and string all wired up to a soundboard that Kurt can program to create whatever sounds he wants. There's Magnus, an electric chord organ, Krieg, the bass guitar, and then there's Rosie, the theremin.
PAM乐队代表部分人工音乐家。库尔特的自动装置是由金属和弦的废料制成的，全部连接到库尔特可以编程以创建任何他想要的声音的音板上。有马格努斯，一台电和弦风琴；克里格，低音吉他；还有罗西，特雷门琴。
This is Jack, a solid body electric violin using the exoskeleton design. This is what helps alleviate the boredom of the redundancy of Phantom, because I'm constantly thinking about this project and how I can improve the automation and the kind of music that I would like to create.
这是杰克，使用外骨骼设计的实体电小提琴。这有助于缓解《魅影》冗余带来的无聊，因为我一直在思考这个项目以及我如何能改进自动化和我想要创作的音乐类型。
Why did you decide to do this?
你为什么决定这样做？
If I ever see a therapist, maybe they will help me understand this.
如果我去看治疗师，也许他们会帮我理解这一点。
Well, pretend I'm a therapist.
好吧，假设我是治疗师。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Was there part of it where you're like, man, I am playing in this orchestra. It's not the expressiveness that I want. I also kind of feel like an automaton, you know? And maybe I'll just make an automaton as a violinist.
有没有一部分是，嘿，伙计，我在这个乐团演奏。这不是我想要的表现力。我也感觉像个机器人，你知道吗？也许我就做一个机器人小提琴手。
Yeah, I mean, I can see exploring that. Am I looking for some kind of soul healing from this dehumanization of being in a violin section? Possibly.
是的，我的意思是，我可以考虑探讨一下。我是不是在寻找某种灵魂疗愈，以摆脱身处小提琴组的那种非人化？也许吧。
I asked Kurt if the PAM Band could play "The Music of the Night," or "All I Ask of You," or any of the Phantom classics. He wasn't into that at all. This band was not designed to play Andrew Lloyd Weber.
我问库尔特PAM乐队能否演奏《夜之乐章》，或是《All I Ask of You》，或者任何《魅影》的经典曲目。他一点也不感兴趣。这个乐队不是为演奏安德鲁·劳埃德·韦伯而设计的。
But something inside him just couldn't get away from Phantom of the Opera. Back when he was sitting in the pit, he'd composed, just in his head, both the prequel and the sequel to Phantom, both which involve Indiana Jones type characters. And years ago, he got a copy of the 1925 silent film version of Phantom and wrote an entire score. He wanted to play it for me. He turned off the lights in the warehouse and projected the film onto the wall. The PAM Band started to play.
但某种东西让他无法远离《歌剧魅影》。当他坐在乐池里时，他已经在脑海中编排了《魅影》的前传和续集，两者都涉及印第安纳·琼斯类型的角色。多年前，他弄到了一份1925年无声电影版《魅影》的拷贝，并写了整部配乐。他想演给我看。他关掉了仓库里的灯，把电影投影到墙上。PAM乐队开始演奏。
The score features him, Kurt, as the solo violinist and the star of the show. The automatons all play the same thing, but Kurt always improvises. None of his shows are ever the same.
配乐以他，也就是库尔特，作为独奏小提琴手和演出明星。所有的自动装置演奏同样的内容，但库尔特总是进行即兴创作。他的节目从来没有哪一场是一样的。
[KURT PLAYING WITH PAM BAND]
[库尔特与PAM乐队演奏中]
Jay Caspian Kang, he's making a documentary about the Phantom pit and is co-host of the podcast, Time to Say Goodbye.
杰·卡斯皮安·康（Jay Caspian Kang），他正在制作一部关于《魅影》乐池的纪录片，也是播客《是时候说再见了》的联合主持人。
[MUSIC - "FOUR WALLS" BY EDDIE HOLMAN]
[音乐 - 埃迪·霍尔曼的《四面墙》]
Our program was produced today by Aviva DeKornfeld. The people who put our program together today include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Noor Gill, Damien Grave, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德制作。今天参与制作我们节目的人包括比姆·阿德温米、埃尔纳·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、努尔·吉尔、达米安·格雷夫、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特、米基·米克、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、娜迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sara Abdurrahman, senior editor, David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to our interpreter, Gabriela Munoz. Also David Lai, Grace Paradise, Isabel Castro, Gleb Mikhalev, Cameron Dennis, Carissa Henderson, Alex Neumann, and Jean Hannah Edelstein.
我们的执行主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼，高级编辑大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。今天特别感谢我们的翻译加布里埃拉·穆诺兹。还有大卫·莱、格蕾丝·天堂、伊莎贝尔·卡斯特罗、格列布·米哈列夫、卡梅伦·丹尼斯、卡丽莎·亨德森、亚历克斯·诺伊曼和让·汉娜·埃德尔斯坦。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. Plus, there's videos. There's lists of favorite programs. There's all kinds of other stuff there. Again, the website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费播放我们超过700集的档案。另外，还有视频。有最喜爱节目的列表。上面还有各种其他东西。再说一遍，网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》通过PRX，公共广播交易所，分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He and I were talking the other day, and he let slip he hasn't been listening to our program for weeks. I was like, what? Totally confronted him about it. And-- I don't know. I guess he had a good reason.
和往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他和我在那天聊天，他漏嘴说他已经几周没听我们的节目了。我当时想，什么？完全和他对质了。而且——我不知道。我想他应该有正当理由。
[SIGHS] I'm just so tired of the sound of your voice.
[叹气] 我实在是受够了你的声音。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week. I told Torey, I get it.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来。我告诉托雷，我明白了。
You know, and I'm tired of the sound of my voice, too. So I kind of sympathize.
你知道，我受够了我自己的声音。所以我多少有些同情。
[MUSIC - "FOUR WALLS" BY EDDIE HOLMAN]
[音乐 - 埃迪·霍尔曼的《四面墙》]